for people that complain that I'm going
after somebody's job for every job I've
had in my entire life as a working man
I've had inter interviews and tests and
exams against hundreds and dozens or
whatever other many people anybody that
has a job has had to take that job off
of somebody else H got his job handed to
him and it just so happens that he's get
some competition some deal with it like
a grownup like an American man would and
like a man anywhere in the world would
you'll have to have again cuz H is still
not going to do it so he's a media
coward that should at least do something
to promote this thing I made him a main
event at this show before I came on kill
Tony he would have been just one more
minute on that show and because I made a
hell of a ton of a big ass promotion for
this thing he's he just became the main
event so yeah hkim you're a more
experienced better funnier nicer more
cherished comedian than I am but without
me you would have just been a regular